[Music]
i know you're all anxious to go home but
we have some housekeeping to take care
of first you received a packet
you're instructed to sign that packet
and return it to me so let's just be
reasonable adults and
sign our packets so we can all go home
sound good
no no no no
we have a meeting with montreal next
week where are we with the expansion
we've been working really well together
i've seen this pattern before
it's the calm before the divorce we are
not your parents
i was talking about my own divorce um
although both apply actually
i have a master's in fine arts wow he
didn't ask for a podcast
that's what i was going to say i was
just going to say that's just so much
information
i feel like we're on the same page we're
really fine yeah something bad is gonna
happen
here we go
i can drive stick okay i my legs are
probably too strong and i'm putting too
much
yeah that's probably it
[Music]
the high pressure and the friction
that's what turns cold into diamonds
yo what's up snoop all right man when
you releasing that new expansion when
you release that new album
you look very cute in that mocap suit
you smell capsule you like this one
oh i wish i could be with you to press
flesh against pledge
it's better that he's remote i'm a
hangout
that shirt is so tight that i can
authentically see your nipples
why are you looking at my nipples it's
hard not to you're kind of asking for it
says victim
blaming you can't blame me you're a
victim of nothing
you